the protests have become a weekly event
and follow a now predictable pattern
they begin as a peaceful march the
demonstrators sometimes being closely
shadowed by police then clashes break
out
and next gunfire as the police attempt
to disperse the crowds
some demonstrators appear to be armed
and the bullets do not only fly in one
direction
the protesters insist they will carry on
until their demands are met
we came to say we want fuel and gas
stations we need money transfers and u.s
dollars we want the cost of living in
haiti to come down we want insecurity to
come down
haiti must be paradise for everyone not
for a small group only the people have
their demands
everything we are asking for must be
clear
otherwise we will never stop the protest
today the system must learn because the
haitian people want to change their
country
the prime minister says his government
is aware of the seriousness of the
situation
and has pledged to fight poverty and
ensure that more fuel is available at
gas stations
but for most in the streets these are
empty promises and the message is clear
the protests will continue until the
long postponed election is held and a
new government replaces the old
mike hanna al jazeera